I want to bring this part of the class
to an end,
so this is our last lecture,
but for our series of guest lectures and
in this talk I hope to address some of
the state of deep learning today and
kind of bring up some of the limitations
of the algorithms that you've been
seeing in this class so far.
So we've got a really good taste of some
of the limitations specifically in
reinforcement learning algorithms that
lex gave in the last lecture and that's
really going to build on a.
or I'm going to use that to build on top
of during this lecture and just to end
on.
I'm gonna bring you.
I'm going to introduce you to some new
frontiers in deep learning that are
really,
really inspiring and that the cutting
edge of research today.
Before we do that,
I'd like to just make some
administrative announcements so tee
shirts have arrived and will be
distributing them today and we'd like to
distribute first to the registered for
credit students.
After that,
we will be happy to distribute to
registered listeners and then after
that,
if there's any remaining goal,
give out to listeners if they'd want,
if they're interested.
So for those of you who are taking this
class for credit,
I need to reiterate what kind of options
you have to actually fulfill your credit
requirement.
So the first option is a group project
proposal presentation.
So for this option,
you'll be given the opportunity to pitch
a novel deep learning idea to a panel of
judges on Friday.
You'll have exactly one minute to make
your pitch as error,
as clear and as concisely as possible.
So this is really difficult to do in one
minute and this kind of one of the
challenges that we're,
we're putting on you in addition to
actually coming up with the deep
learning idea itself.
If you want to go down this route for
your final project,
then you'll need to submit your teams,
which have to be of size three or four
by the end of today.
So at 9:00
PM today,
we'd like those in,
um,
you'll have to do teams of three and
four.
So if you want a group working in groups
of one or two,
then you'll have to,
you're,
you're welcome to do that,
but you won't be able to actually submit
or final project as part of a
presentation on Friday.
You can submit it to us and we'll,
we'll give you the grade for the class
like that.
Um,
so groups are do 9:00
PM today and you have to submit your
slides by 9:00
PM tomorrow.
Presentations or our class on Friday in
this room.
If you don't want to do a project or a
presentation,
you have a second option,
which is to write a one page paper
review of a deep learning idea.
Uh,
so any idea or any paper that you find
interesting is,
is welcome here.
So we really accept anything and we're
really free in this,
in this,
um,
option as well.
I want to highlight some of the exciting
new talks that we have coming up after
today.
So tomorrow we'll have two sets of guest
lectures.
First we'll hear from Ernest Mueller,
who is the chief architect of and videos
self driving car team.
So erzen and his team were actually
known for some really exciting work that
Aldo is showing yesterday during her
lecture and they're known for this
development of an end to end platform
for autonomous driving that takes
directly image data and produces a
steering control command at the car for
the car at the output.
Then we'll hear about,
we'll hear from two google brain
researchers on recent advancements on
image classification at Google.
And also we'll hear about some super
recent advancements and additions to the
tensorflow pipeline that we're actually
just released a couple of days ago.
So this is really,
really new stuff.
Uh,
tomorrow afternoon we'll get together
for one of the most exciting parts of
this class.
Um,
so what will happen is we'll have each
of the sponsors actually come up to the
front of the class here.
We have four sponsors that will present
on each of these four boards and you'll
be given the opportunity to basically
connect with each of them through the,
uh,
through the ways of a recruitment booth.
And basically they're going to be
looking at students that might be
interested in deep learning internships
or employment opportunities.
So this is really an incredible
opportunity for you guys to connect with
these companies in a very,
very,
very direct manner.
So we highly recommend that you take
advantage of that.
There'll be info sessions with pizza
provided on Thursday with one of these
guests lecture with one of these
industry companies and we'll be sending
out more details with that today as
well.
So on Friday we'll continue with the
guest lectures and hear from Lisa and
meany who is the head of IBM research
and Cambridge.
She's actually also the,
uh,
director of the MIT IBM lab.
And this is a lab that was just founded
a couple or actually about a month ago
or two months ago.
We'll be hearing about how IBM is
creating ai systems that are capable of
not only deep learning,
we're going to step past deep learning,
they're capable of or trying to be
capable of learning and recently on a
higher order sense.
And then finally we'll hear from a
principal researcher at ten cent ai lab
about combining computer vision and
social networks.
It's a very interesting topic that we
haven't really touched upon in this
class.
I'm just topic of social networks and
using massive big data collected from
from humans themselves.
And then as I mentioned before,
in the afternoon,
we'll go through and hear about the
final project presentations.
We'll celebrate with some pizza and the
awards that will be given out to the top
projects during those during that
session as well.
So now let's start with the technical
content for this class,
I'd like to start by just kind of
overviewing the type of architectures
that we've talked about so far.
For the most part,
these architectures can be thought of
almost pattern recognition architecture.
So they take us input data and the whole
point of their pipeline,
their internals are performing feature
extraction and and what they're really
doing is taking all of the century data,
trying to figure out what are the
important pieces,
what are the patterns to be learned
within the data such that they can
produce a decision at the output.
We've seen this take many forms,
so the decision could be a prediction,
could be a detection or even an action
like in reinforcement learning setting.
We've even learned how these models can
be viewed in a generative sense to go in
the opposite direction.
It actually generate new synthetic data,
but in general we've been dealing with
algorithms that are really optimized to
do well and only a single task,
but they really failed to think like
humans do,
especially when we consider a higher
order level of intelligence like I
defined on the first day.
To understand this in a lot more detail,
we have to go back to this very famous
theorem,
those dating back almost 30 years from
today,
the steering,
which is known as the universal
approximation.
Durham was one of the most impactful
theorems in neural networks when it
first came out because it had such a
profound.
It such a profound claim.
What it states is that a neural network
with a single hidden layer is sufficient
to approximate any function to any
arbitrary level of accuracy.
Now,
in this class,
we deal with networks that are deep.
They're not single.
Layered,
so they're actually more than a single
layer,
so actually they continue to add more
complexity than the network down,
referring to here,
but this theorem proves that we actually
only need one layer to accomplish or to
approximate any function in the world,
and if you believe that any problem can
actually be reduced to a sets of inputs
and outputs and it's a form of a
function than this theory on shows you
that a neural network with just a single
layer is able to solve any problem in
the world.
Now,
this is an incredibly powerful result,
but if you look closely,
there are a few very important caveats.
I'm not actually telling you how large
that hidden layer has to be to
accomplish this task.
Now,
with the size of your problem,
the hidden layer and the number of units
in that hidden layer,
maybe exponentially large.
I know grow exponentially with the
difficulty of your problem.
This makes training that network very
difficult,
so I never actually told you anything
about how to obtain that network.
I just told you that it existed and
there is a possible network in the realm
of all neural networks that can solve
that problem,
but as we know in practice,
actually training neural networks
because of their noncombat structure is
extremely difficult.
So this term is really a perfect example
of the possible effects of overhyping in
Ai.
So over the history of ai we've had to
ai winters and this theorem was one of
the resurgence after the first day I
went there,
but it also caused a huge false hype in
the power of these neural networks which
ultimately lead to yet another ai
winter.
And I feel like as a class it's very
important to bring this up because right
now we're very much in the state of a
huge amount of overhyping and deep
learning algorithms.
So these algorithms are,
especially in the media being portrayed
that they can accomplish human level
intelligence and human level reasoning
and simply this is not true.
So I think such overhype is extremely
dangerous and resulted well.
We know it resulted in both of the two
past ai winters and I think as a class
that's very important for us to focus on
some of the limitations of these
algorithms so that we don't overhype
them,
but we provide realistic guarantees,
are realistic expectations rather on
what these algorithms can accomplish and
finally going past these limitations.
The last part of this talk will actually
focus on some of the exciting research,
like I mentioned before,
that tries to take a couple of these
limitations and really focus on possible
solutions and possible ways that we can
move past them.
Okay,
so let's start and I think one of the
best examples of a potential danger of
neural networks comes from this paper
from Google deep mind,
a named understanding deep neural
networks requires rethinking
generalization and generalizations was
this topic that we discussed in the
first lecture.
So this is the notion of a gap or a
difference between your training
accuracy and your test accuracy.
If you're able to achieve equal training
and test accuracy,
that means you have essentially no
generalization gap.
You're able to generalize perfectly to
to your test data set,
but if there's a huge disparity between
these two datasets in your model is
performing much better on your training
data set than your test data.
So this means that you're not able to
actually generalize to brand new images.
You're only just memorizing the training
examples.
And what this paper did was they
performed the following experiment,
so they took images from image net so he
can see four examples of these images
here.
And what they did was they rolled a case
I did die where k is the number of all
possible labels in that data set and
this allowed them to randomly assigned
brand new labels to each of these
images.
So what used to be a dog,
they call it now a banana and what they
were used to be,
that banana is now called the dog and
what it used to be called that second
dog is now a tree.
So note that the two dogs have actually
been transformed into two separate
things.
So things that used to be in the same
class are now in completely disjoined
classes and things that were in
destroying classes may be now in the
same class.
So basically we're completely
randomizing our labels entirely.
And what they did was they tried to see
if a neural network could still learn
random labels and here's what they
found.
So as you'd expect when they tested this
neural network with random labels,
as they increase the randomness on the x
axis,
so going from left to right,
this is the original labels before
randomizing anything,
and then they started randomizing their
test accuracy gradually decreased.
And this is as expected because we're
trying to learn something that has
absolutely no pattern in it.
But then what's really interesting is
that then they looked at the training
accuracy and what they found was that
the neural network was able to,
with 100 percent accuracy,
get the training said correct.
Every single time,
no matter how many random labels they
introduced,
the training set would always be
shattered or another words.
Every single example in the training
side could be perfectly classified.
So this means that modern deep neural
networks actually have the capacity to
brute force memorize massive data sets,
even on the size of image net with
completely random labels.
They're able to memorize every single
example in that data set.
And this is a very powerful result is it
drives home this point that neural
networks are really,
really excellent function approximators.
So this also connects back to the
universal approximation theorem that I
talked about before,
but they're really good approximators
for just the single function like I
said,
which means that we can always create
this maximum likelihood estimate of our
data using a neural network such that if
we were given a new data points like
this purple one on the bottom,
it's easy for us to compute is estimate
probability estimate output just by
intercepting it with that maximum
likelihood estimate,
but that's only if I'm looking at a
place that we have sufficient training
data already.
What if I extend this x axes and look at
what the neural network predicts beyond
that in these locations.
These are actually the locations that we
care about most,
right?
These are the edge cases and driving.
These are the cases that we don't have
mit,
many or a lot of data that was collected
and these are usually the cases were
safety.
Critical applications are like are most
important,
right?
So we need to be able to make sure when
we sampled in neural network from these
locations,
are we able to know that the neural
network,
are we able to get feedback from the
neural network that it actually doesn't
know what it's talking about.
So this notion leads nicely into the
idea of what is known as advertar
adversarial attacks where I can give you
can give and neural network to images on
the left like this one,
and on the right and adversarial image
that to a human look exactly the same,
but to the network,
they're incorrectly classified 100
percent of the time.
So the image on the right shows an
example of a temple which when I feed to
a neural network and gives me back label
of a temple,
but when I apply some adversarial noise,
it classifies this image incorrectly as
an ostrich.
So for this,
I'd like to focus on this piece
specifically,
so to understand the limitations of
neural networks,
the first thing we have to do is
actually understand how we can break
them,
and this perturbed noise is actually
very
intelligently designed,
so this is not just random noise,
but we're actually modifying pixels in
specific locations to maximally change
or mess up or output prediction.
So we want to modify the pixels in such
a way that we're decreasing our accuracy
as much as possible.
And if you remember back to how we
actually train our neural networks,
this might sound very similar.
So if you're a member training,
a neural network is simply optimizing
over our weights feta.
So to do this,
we simply compute the gradients of Feta
with sorry,
the great into our last function with
respect to theater,
and we simply perturb our weights in the
direction that will minimize our loss.
Now also remember that when we do this,
we're perturbing theater,
but we're fixing or x in our y.
This is our training label.
Our training data and returning labels.
Now,
for adversarial examples were just
shuffling the variables a little bit,
so now we want to optimize over the
image itself,
not the wage,
so we fixed the weights and the target
label itself and we optimize over the
image x.
We want to make small changes to that
image x such that we increased our loss
as much as possible and we want to go in
the opposite direction of training now,
and these are just some of the
limitations of neural networks and for
the remainder of this class,
I want to focus on some of the really,
really exciting new frontiers of deep
learning that focus on just two of these
specifically.
I want to focus on the notion of
understanding uncertainty and deep
neural networks and understanding when
our model doesn't know what it was
trained to know.
Maybe because it wasn't.
It didn't receive enough training data
to support that hypothesis.
And furthermore,
I wanted to focus on this notion of
learning how to learn models.
Because optimization of neural networks
is extremely difficult.
It's extremely limited and its current
nature because they're optimized just to
do a single test.
So what we really want to do is create
neural networks that are capable of
performing one task,
but a set of sequences of tasks that are
maybe dependent in some fashion.
So let's start with this notion of
uncertainty in deep neural networks.
And to do that,
I'd like to introduce this field called
Bayesian deep learning.
Nope.
To understand beige and deep learning.
Let's understand why we even care about
uncertainty.
So this should be pretty obvious.
Let's suppose we're given a network that
was trained to distinguish between cats
and dogs at input.
We're given a lot of testing or training
images of cats and dogs,
and it's simply at the output we're
producing an output probability of being
a cat or a dog.
Now,
this model is trained on either on only
cats or dogs.
So if I showed another cat,
it should be very confident in its
output,
but let's suppose I give it a horse and
I forced that network because it's the
same network to produce an output being
a probability of a cat or a probability
of a dog.
Now we know that these probabilities
have to add up to one because that's
actually the definition that we
constrain our network to follow.
So that means by definition one of these
categories,
so the network has to produce one of
these categories,
so the notion of probability and the
notion of uncertainty are actually very
different,
but a lot of deep learning practitioners
optin mixed these two ideas,
so uncertainty is not probability.
Neural networks or detect are trained to
detect or produce probabilities at three
output at their output,
but they're not trained to produce
uncertainty values.
So if we put this horse into the same
network,
we'll get a set of uncertain of
probability values that add up to one.
But what we really want to see is we
want to see a very low uncertainty in
that very low certainty in that
prediction.
And one possible way to accomplish this
in deep learning is through the eyes of
Bayesian deep learning.
And to understand this,
let's briefly start by formulating our
problem again.
So first let's go through like the
variables,
right?
So we want to approximate this variable
y or output y given some raw data x.
and really what we mean by training is
we want to find this functional mapping
f parameterized by our weights data such
that we minimize the loss between our
predict examples and our true outputs.
Why?
So based on neural networks take a
different approach to solve this
problem,
they aim to learn it postier over our
weights,
given the data.
So they attempt to say,
what is the probability that I see this
model with these weights given the data
in my training set.
Now it's called Bayesian deep learning
because we can simply have a rewrite
this posterior using bayes rule.
However,
in practice it's rarely possible to
actually compute this compute,
this bayes rule,
updates,
and it just turns out to be intractable.
So instead we have to find out ways to
actually approximate it through
sampling.
So one way that we'll talk about today
is a very simple notion that we've
actually already seen in the first.
And it goes back to this idea of using
dropout.
So if you're a member,
what dropout was dropped out is this
notion of randomly killing off a certain
percentage of neurons in each of the
hidden layers.
Now I'm going to tell you not how to use
it as a regular advisor,
but how to use dropbox as a way to
produce reliable uncertainty measures
for your neural network.
So to do this,
we have to think of capital t stochastic
passes through our network where each
stochastic pass performance one
iteration of dropouts.
Each time you iterate,
dropout,
you're basically just applying a
Bernoulli mask of ones and Zeros over
each of your weights.
So going from the left to the right,
you can see our weights,
which is like this matrix here.
Different colors represent the intensity
of that weight and we element wise
multiply those weights by our Bernoulli
mask with,
which is just either a one or a zero in
every location.
The output is a new set of weights with
certain of those dropped out with
certain aspects of those dropped out.
Now all we have to do is compute this t
times capital t times.
We'll get a feta t weights and we use
those stated t different models to
actually produce an empirical average of
our output class given the data.
So that's this guy.
Well,
we're actually really interested in why
I brought this topic up was the notion
of uncertainty though,
and that's the variance of our
predictions right there.
So this is a very powerful idea.
All it means is that we can attain
reliable model uncertainty estimates
simply by trading our network during run
time with dropout.
And then instead of estimating or
classifying just a single pass through
this network at test time,
we'd classify capital t two iterations
of this network and then use that to
compute a variance over these outputs.
And that variance gives us an estimation
of our uncertainty.
Not to give you an example of how this
looks in practice.
Let's look at this,
uh,
this network that was trained to take as
input images of the real world and
outputs predicted depth maps.
Oh,
it looks like my text was a little off.
That's okay.
So at the output we have a predicted
death,
not for each pixel to network is
predicting the depth in the real world
of that Pixel.
Now,
when we run Bayesian model uncertainty
using the exact same dropout method that
I just described,
we can see that the end,
the model is most uncertain in some very
interesting locations.
So first of all,
pay attention to that location right
there.
And if you look where,
where is that location exactly?
It's just the window sill of this car
and in computer vision windows and
specular objects are very difficult to
to basically model because we can't
actually tell their surface reliably,
right?
So we're seeing the light from actually
the sky.
We're not actually seeing the surface of
the window in that location,
so it can be very difficult for us to
model the depth in that place.
Additionally,
we see that the model is very uncertain
on the edges of the cars because these
are places where the depth is changing
very rapidly,
so the prediction may be least accurate
and these locations.
So having reliable uncertainty estimates
can be an extremely powerful way to
actually interpret deep learning models
and also provide human practitioners,
especially in the realm of safe ai,
is the way to interpret the results and
also trust our results with a certain
amount or a certain gram of salt.
So for the next and final part of this
talk,
I'd like to address this notion of
learning to learn.
So this is a really cool sounding topic.
It aims to basically learn not just a
single model that's optimized to perform
a single task like we've learned
basically in all of our lectures
previous to this one,
but it learns how to learn which model
to use to train that task.
So first,
let's understand why we might want to do
something like that.
I hope this is pretty obvious to by now,
but humans are not built in a way where
we're learning where we're executing
just a single task at a time were
executing many,
many,
many different tasks and all of these
tasks are constantly interacting with
each other in ways that learning one
task can actually aid speed up or deter
the learning.
You have another task at any given time,
modern deep neural network architectures
and not like this.
They're optimized for a single task and
this goes back to the very beginning of
this talk where we talked about the
universal approximator and as these
models become more and more complex,
what ends up happening is that you have
to have more and more expert knowledge
to actually build and deploy these
models in practice and that's exactly
why all of you are here.
You're here to basically get that
experience such that you yourselves can
build these deep learning models.
So what we want is actually an automated
machine learning framework where we can
actually learn to learn and this
basically means we want to build a model
that learns which model to use given a
problem definition.
One example I'd like to just use as an
illustration of this idea,
so there are many ways that auto ml can
be accomplished and this is just one
example of those ways.
So I'd like to focus on this
illustration here and I'd like to walk
through it.
It's just a way that we can learn to
learn.
So this,
this system focuses on two parts.
The first part is the controller rnn in
red on the left,
and this controller rnn is basically
just sampling different architectures of
neural networks.
So if you remember in your first lab you
created an rnn that could sample
different music notes.
This is no different except now we're
not sampling music notes.
We're sampling an entire neural network
itself.
So we're sampling parameters that define
that neural network.
So let's call that the architecture or
the child network.
So that's the network that will actually
be used to solve our task in the end.
So that network has passed on to the
second bop.
second one.
And in that piece we actually used that
network that was generated by the rnn to
train a model depending on how well that
model did,
we can provide feedback to the rnn such
that it can produce an even better model
on the next time step.
So let's go into this piece by piece.
Let's look at just the rnn part in more
detail.
So this is the rnn or the architecture
generator.
So like I said,
this is very similar to the way that you
are generating songs and your first lab,
except now we're not generating songs,
the timestamps are going from layers on
the x axis and we're just generating
parameters or hyper parameters rather
for each of those layers.
So this is a generator for a
convolutional neural network because
we're producing parameters like the
filter height,
the filter with the stride height,
etc.
So what we can do is we can at each time
step produce a probability distribution
of over each of these parameters and we
can essentially just sample and
architecture or sample of child network.
Once we have that child network,
which I'm Showing right here in blue,
we can train it using our data set that
we ultimately want to solve.
So we put our training data in and we
get our predicted labels out.
This is the,
this is the realm that we've been
dealing with so far in this class,
right?
So we have our,
this is basically what we've seen so
far.
So this is just a single network and we
have our training data that we're using
to train it.
We see how well this does,
depending on the accuracy of this model,
that accuracy is used to provide
feedback back to the rnn and update how
it produces or how it generates these
models.
So let's look at this one more time.
To summarize,
this is an extremely powerful idea.
It's really,
really,
really exciting because it shows that an
rnn can be actually combined in a
reinforcement learning paradigm where
the rnn itself is almost like the agent
in reinforcement learning.
It's learning to make changes to the
child network architecture.
Depending on how that child network
performs on a training set,
this means that we're able to create an
ai system capable of generating brand
new neural networks specialized to solve
specific tasks rather than just creating
a single neural network that we create
just to solve that tasks that we want to
create that we want to solve.
Thus,
this has significantly reduced.
The difficulty in optimizing these
neural networks for our architecture is
for different tasks and it's also
reduces the need for expert engineers to
design these architectures,
so this really gets at the heart of
artificial intelligence.
So when I began this course,
we spoke about what it actually means to
be intelligent and lucy.
I defined this as the ability to take
information,
process that information,
and use it to inform future decisions.
So the human learning pipeline is not
restricted to solving just one task at a
time.
Like I mentioned before,
how we learn one task can greatly impact
speed up or even slowed down our
learning of other tasks and the
artificial models that we've created
today.
Simply do not capture this phenomenon.
To reach artificial general
intelligence.
We need to actually build ai that can
not only learn a single task,
but also be able to improve its own
learning and reasoning such that it can
generalize to sets of related and
dependent tasks.
I'll leave this with you as a thought
provoking points that encourage you to
to all talk to each other on on some
ways that we can reach this,
this higher order level of intelligence
that's not just pattern recognition,
but rather a higher order form of
reasoning and actually thinking about
about the problems that we're trying to
solve.
Thank you.